if you're a fan of Ratchet and Clank or
sunset overdrive you're probably looking
forward to whatever insomniac games does
next well that new game is called song
of the deep and it's coming this spring
song of the deep is a 2d side scrolling
Metroidvania starring a 12 year old
named Marin she sets out to find her
missing father by piloting a submarine
through underwater cities and caves the
story is based on Celtic and irish myths
with cutscenes that look like a picture
book the Metroidvania elements come into
play with marin sub which she can update
with hook shots laser cannons in sonar
and of course she'll face plenty of
giant bosses and environmental puzzles
on her expedition that's on top of
deep-sea enemies like clams and angler
fish and anemones Marin may just be
Samus I ran for a new generation song of
the deep will launch digitally on ps4
xbox one and pc later this spring for 15
bucks you can also get a retail disk
exclusively a gamestop they're actually
publishing the game but for more news
and reviews on song of the deep keep it
locked at gamespot